what's your biggest regret  I would say  um digging them Graves up was probably  my biggest [ __ ] mistake because my  grandma came up to me and said I'm  getting hauled away she goes if  how would you feel if that was your  grandpa and I was like oh man I'd kill  somebody over that [ __ ] and she goes  well how do you think this town feels  and I'm like well yeah that's why they  want you gone never to come back so I  left and never I never been back  never been back to my hometown since  what are you afraid of now at 50. um  same thing as always cops that's it  that's all I'm afraid of I'm not afraid  of dying I'm ready to go but uh yeah  cots  cops can take me from my dogs man and  that is just killing me I mean it's like  I said they're my life that's all I live  for is in dogs